zambia we're going to hear so the title
of the talk was slightly changed from
the schedule i think you can see it for
yourself at least some some of this work
presented he received the best paper
award in best student paper wallet
called in the the student representing
it was one wang who is now joining Yahoo
soon and then in the Yale and other
collaborators that I'm sure gonna saying
that's it I mean okay alright great so
thank you to the organizers for the
opportunity to be here today um so what
I'd like to do today is tell you about
some of our recent work on modeling and
analysis of visual data so my
collaborators and I are interested in um
in data sets and and problems that come
from applications in imaging and vision
so questions like how we can compute
with large sets of images large sets of
videos how we can solve practical
problems like recognition denoising
classification and you know it's pretty
clear in some sense where we're here to
talk about concise sources sync data
representations it's pretty clear to
have that to have any hope in problems
that we're we're dealing with you know
observations and millions of dimensions
or billions of dimensions we're going to
need some notion of structure in the
data so we need to know structurally
what's going on here in these very large
sets of high-dimensional data so our
problem really is how we can extract
some kind of useful low dimensional
structure in high-dimensional imagery
data and this could be physical
structure it could come from the process
that generate the data it could be
geometric structure so here mixtures of
subspaces it could be some kind of
statistical structure and so will
actually see all of these notions in the
talk but anyway the question is really
how do we capture structure in an
imaging problems in service of
applications
and so what I'd like to do today is I'd
like to tell you about a couple of
results of that pertain to this problem
really talking about in some sense two
methodologies for getting at the
structure and high dimensional data so
we'll talk about a kind of classical
analytical methodology where we sit down
and we think very very carefully about
the process that generated our data we
try to analyze properties of the data
set and from that drive good
representations we'll talk a little bit
about the kind of statements that we can
make in one very specific application
and then in the last part of the talk
will transition into some questions
about how we can learn good models
automatically so if we don't know as
much or we're in a situation where our
structure of interest is more
statistical and less physical or
geometric what can we do so so this is
the the broad outline of the talk um so
i'm going to start the the beginning of
the talk actually very very very narrow
in some sense so we'll talk about one
very specific application and then from
there will branch out a little bit so
the application that I'm interested in
is in visual recognition so the
situation is the following we have an
object of interest maybe it's human face
maybe it's something else and we would
like to know if this object is present
in some new input image so I have some
information about the object you know
maybe I have a model maybe I have some
training images and eventually I would
like to detect or recognize this in a
new image and so there are a lot of very
interesting engineering questions that
you can ask here in terms of analysis of
high-dimensional data the question is
really what we need to do this well so
if we want to have an algorithm that say
in some sense guarantees to detector
recognize this object what do we need to
know what are the resources that are
needed both in terms of computation and
in terms of data okay so I have the
object I'd like to recognize it in the
new image now one of the fun things
about working on problems of this nature
is that at
the difficulties are kind of obvious you
know you just look around and you see
see what the challenges are the
challenges are that objects move around
lighting conditions change and objects
can include each other so these sort of
very simple to state but difficult to
compute with um phenomena these kind of
physical nuisances so in terms of
mathematics for this talk I'm only going
to describe what we need to do for fixed
pose thinking about variations in
illumination and perhaps some occlusion
okay so so even restrict the problem a
little bit more ask what do we really
need to know about the data in order to
solve the problem now since this is you
know this is an imaging problem this is
largely an engineering field it's worth
talking about popular engineering
approaches to the problem and there
broadly speaking to I would say two
fundamental lines of approach on
problems like this that really depend on
what you want from the application so if
you need to be very scalable if you want
to work across the internet then you
know you're kind of forced to work with
very simple image representations so
what people will do is they will try to
mitigate these nuisances by making a
clever choice of features so you make
you choose some time when your features
and then you do some kind of a near
neighbour or nearest neighbor search
maybe do some more sophisticated
learning on top of that but the basic
idea is to work through the features and
for problems where you really need to be
very scalable this is essentially the
best thing that we know and you know
there's there's a lot of work that's
been sort of improving this over time
before problems where we really need
high recognition rates or potentially
where we want guarantees um there's
another approach that seems promising in
some sense which is to use the physics
of the process that generated the data
and you know this is again a very old
idea and it's it's also kind of a fun
one to play with in the sense that it
leaves you with
representations and algorithms that are
actually very simple so once you cast
the problem as one of representing the
collection of images that you're going
to encounter then this recognition or
verification problem just becomes one of
regression against that set and so
people do things like make linear models
for the the set of images that you
encounter for example under varying
elimination and then the kind of
regression or optimization problem that
you would have to solve is just a linear
regression so here I I write my input as
a linear combination of the training
database plus some error and of course
here the error is capturing something
physical it's capturing the seclusion
okay so basically this this this
methodology and you know this is not of
course not the only work that takes this
methodology this methodology really puts
the onus on having a good representation
for this high dimensional imagery data
so if we do well with the model then we
really should expect to do well in terms
of the application now it is worth
mentioning that the computational
problems that you encounter especially
when you're trying to compute with
errors so when you want to be robust um
are fundamentally hard so for example if
I I want to correct a sparse air I want
to deal with occlusion then you know in
the worst case there may not be too much
that I can do but you know I think as as
most of us are aware there are very good
relaxation for dealing with these kind
of errors dealing with corruption
corruption corrupted linear regression
and we can make and I think at least
fairly satisfying statements about the
performance of linear regression when
the model fits so what I've put up here
is a result with with g'ma this one was
motivated by the application and so the
model is maybe not as elegant or
homogeneous is the ones that are studied
by you know others in the room but it
kind of captures in some sense what we
would expect and what it says is that if
you have a if you have a linear model if
Y is actually equal
x + e x is sparse enough e is sparse
enough and a satisfies some appropriate
property so it is nice enough in some
sense then you actually can make very
nice statements about the performance of
l1 regression so in some sense the the
bottleneck here you know if we want to
really take this from making pictures
and graphs to really being able to make
strong statements about the performance
of the algorithm the bottleneck here is
really the modeling question the
question of you know when does this
actually fit how well does this capture
the physics in the data ok so it seems
that if we want to make progress we need
to understand a little bit more about
where our images where are where our
problem comes from ok so there's a
fairly standard model for image
formation and computer vision and
computer graphics that says I have my
object here of interest you maybe it's
my my face and I'm going to imagine at
least for the theorems that I'll show
you later that the illumination is
distant so illumination is directional
so I have my lighting which is a
function of direction so you can imagine
that this is defined on the sphere in
high-dimensional or excuse me is defined
on the sphere it's a non negative
function and we're going to imagine that
it's it's nice in a technical sense so I
have light that's a function that
bounces off my face maybe intro reflects
a little bit and then impinges on the
sensor and I'm going to tell one lie
here which is I'm going to ignore
quantization of the sensor so I'm going
to imagine that we have a linear sensor
response so if that's the case this
process of light transport is linear and
so what we have is we have in some sense
the image of the lighting condition
under a linear map so if I'm interested
in thinking about the collection of
lighting conditions that I could
encounter you know if I think about all
of the non-negative functions on the
sphere say all of the non-negative
functions on the sphere that are nice
enough on
that's actually going to give me a
convex cone in the image space and the
reason for this is fairly simple if i
take sums or non-negative multiples of
riemann integrable functions I get
another reminder triple function so the
lighting conditions form a cone I push
that through this linear operator I get
a cone in the image space and this has
been known for a long time in computer
vision Yin this is kind of a fundamental
object in talking about elimination and
variance or building illumination
invariant algorithms ok so our set of
interest is a convex cone now this
convex cone does contain some lighting
conditions that are you know in some
sense unlikely to be encountered in
practice so as an example this would
include for example the situation where
you know I'm at the campfire I take the
flashlight and put it under my face and
I create you know some very horrific
image that's very difficult for us to
process so um one thing that you can do
is you can actually think about a
collection of cones so this c0 is the
cone that I introduced on the last slide
this is the set of all images that you
might encounter under variations in the
lighting um you can make a collection C
alpha that's indexed by alpha which is
the fraction of ambient lighting ok so
geometrically is alpha gets bigger these
things get more and more point more and
more pointy so they collapse towards an
ambient image and so what we would hope
is that if alpha is bigger than it's
easier to represent this object ok but
basically if I if I want to solve this
problem with you know some notion that
I'm doing the correct thing then my
problem is really one of approximating
the set of images that I could encounter
so approximating this convex cone and
there are several ways that you might go
about approximating a convex cone but in
some sense here the natural one is
really V or vertex approximation so so
here these vertices are just all
non-negative multiples of a given image
and so it's it's very natural it says I
approximate everything as the kind of
call of just a few things okay so we
have a collection of convex cones and
the representation that we're looking
for is a vertex approximation and so you
can ask yourself well if I want to build
this approximation what notion of
approximation do I need to think about
so what's the right way to measure how
well I'm doing and it turns out you know
if you just think a little bit um it
turns out that if you want to make a
statement that says that my
representation will accept any image
that's sufficiently close to an image of
me and will reject any image that's
sufficiently far from an image of me
then the right notion of approximation
is really one of one in hausdorff sense
so we would like to build an
approximation in hausdorff sense to this
to this object um now i should say cones
are homogeneous so when we say hausdorff
sense we really mean we intersect with
the sphere but this is what we would
like to do we would like to build an
approximation and hausdorff sense to the
collection of images that i'm going to
see okay so kind of the natural thing to
do then is to look at the literature on
approximation of convex cones and there
are a couple of literature's that the
deal with this question on on various
levels on there's obviously work in
geometry as well as in theoretical
computer science the kinds of statements
that you can make for general cones and
high dimensions are fairly pessimistic
and this is you know in some sets not
surprising if you have an object in very
high dimensions it's hard to a pro in
general it's hard to approximate it
accurately so if you think of examples
like a like a circular cone in high
dimensions you really need a very large
number of extreme raised to approximate
that with with any reasonable accuracy
okay so another line of work that's
relevant to this comes in the computer
vision literature so you know people
like Ravi ramamurthy who's done a lot of
work using using these kinds of models
for for computer graphics applications
and the kinds of statements that you get
in that literature deal a little bit
more with the physics of the particular
cone so this is an example of a the kind
of result that you can claim on what it
says is if I think about very very
simple objects so I think about the
Lamberson sphere for example or other
convex slim version objects if I imagine
that I have a single point source and
it's oriented uniformly at random then
there's this subspace of very low
dimension that captures most of the
energy of that collection of images so
if I imagine that I take the expectation
over this uniformly oriented point
source on in expectation for the convex
object I do quite well ok so that's
that's very motivating that actually
motivated a lot of the work that you saw
at the at the beginning of the talk on
the other hand if we really want
confidence in our representation we have
to worry a little bit here because the
objects that we care about and practice
are often not convex it's a very visual
example of this you know you think about
a person with the nose it takes a fairly
extreme act to turn that into a convex
object and this actually shows up when
you think about the collection of images
you know actually cast shadows play a
very large role in them in determining
how easy your hard it is to approximate
this collection of images and so the
basic up shot here is that if we want a
very accurate representation we're going
to need to use some extra structure in
the data and so the special structure
that I'll use on is just actually very
simple fact it's this observation that
if we look at this cone its extreme
razor actually what could be considered
as images under point illumination so I
imagine that I have a point source say
up there it's eliminating me and I think
about the the collection of all such
images that I could generate so you know
I point source lives on a
two-dimensional space that's
cutting out a low dimensional sub
manifold of this high dimensional image
space now I've put sub manifold in
quotes here it turns out that this map
from the lighting direction to the image
is continuous but it's not Lipschitz due
to the presence of edges and so this is
a sub manifold but in some sense but
it's it's not a very nice one in some
sense non differentiable so they're
going to be some challenges for
approximating this thing but anyway this
is the this is the basic structure that
we have and it's not too difficult to
show that if you can well approximate
these extreme raise then you can well
approximate the code ok and so the kind
of result that you can obtain then if
you do a little bit of analysis is you
can say well if I sit down and I try to
approximate this collection of extreme
raise how many examples am I actually
going to need to be able to do this well
so you could define a kind of covering
number for this set and this is going to
depend on properties of your object and
properties of your imaging system um in
particular it depends on a notion of
convexity defect of the object so that's
what this this high star parameter here
is capturing so we have two terms here
in the bound one is a smooth term that's
coming from these smooth variations
that's sort of what would be well
approximated by the convex Lamberson
model and then we have a second
non-smooth term that's really capturing
the edges or the cash shadows so if we
put them together then we can get bounds
on the number of examples that we need
to do well here and so in particular if
your object is convex then you can do
well with about 1 over gamma squared
examples where gamma is your target
hausdorff distance if your object is non
convex then you need one over gamma to
the 4 which is you know it's polynomial
in your target error although it's not
the friendliest polynomial in the world
but in any case it's possible to say
something
now actually this for comes from a
fairly simple place so there are two
degrees two degrees of freedom and the
placement of the light source and then
there's an extra factor of two here
that's lost just because of non
smoothness due to the moving boundaries
from edges okay so this is the kind of
thing that you can say about the quality
of the the quality of the representation
now this is very very specific this is
probably a little bit too specific for
the interests of most of the audience
here on actually though the the
technology that that gives us this
touches on things that I think are of
interest to most of us um so if you look
at how you would go about trying to
prove a result of this nature the basic
challenge is how you can capture or
account for of these cast shadows so how
do you calculate the error that you
incur and it turns out that the the
proof uses a kind of interesting fact
about this collection of images that you
might encounter under varying
elimination its collection of extreme
rays and that fact is that this thing
can be for certain them for certain
reflectance models can be decomposed as
something that's low dimensional so this
low rank and something else that is
spatially sparse and so actually there's
another kind of nice property of the set
of images that's really underlying all
of this so you know in some sense the
structure is very intricate we start out
looking at a cone it's extreme raise lie
on a sub manifold those extreme raise
viewed as a matrix are low rank and
sparse so it can pose decomposed d into
the owl in the s and this low these kind
of low rank and sparse models are
actually of great interest
computationally for you know actually a
lot of different problems um problems
and doing robust analysis of large data
sets so there the sparsity would be the
error you know here the people in the in
the video probably
xin learning latent variable graphical
models and you know a lot of other
things that have been have been looked
at that I think are of quite a bit of
interest for this kind of big data
phenomenon or big data community um and
you know one of the reasons that these
models are interesting is that they
actually come with very good
computational tools so there's a there's
a very nice convex relaxation for taking
a given matrix so this is your input D
and decomposing it into the will rank
and the sparse term so this first
appears in published work by
chandrasekharan and they also have some
very nice analysis of this this
formulation on there are a number of
results in the literature that you
basically quantify when this thing works
well this is a result with Emmanuel
Kenda's and suddenly on what these
results tell you roughly is that if
you're in the kind of situation that we
see here you know if you're in the
situation where you have a physical
model and so there's really reason to
believe this this l + s and these L&S
don't look too much like each other so
here this L satisfies a technical
incoherence condition this s satisfies a
Bernoulli model then you actually do get
exact recovery here okay so you know in
some sense we started out very very
specific very application driven but we
got to a very general model something
that you know has has a lot of
applications in different places on the
other hand if you look at the chronology
of this work it it took quite a while to
get there you know if we go from the
beginning of the talk to this result on
quality of approximation this is at
least four years of sort of sweat and
calculation and you know just mucking
around with the problem and so you know
in some sense that's that's that's
satisfying but that that's also also
very specific and given the number of
new types of data that we're seeing you
know almost almost on a daily basis than
the number of new problems
reasonable to ask whether it's actually
possible to bypass to some extent this
process so can we get away with learning
the structural model without knowing as
much about the physics of the situation
so you know is there is there some way
of bypassing at least to some extent
this this this kind of tedious process
of analysis and of course the answer is
no if you want really strong statements
but for a lot of practical applications
the answer seems to be yes so there's
really great interest in in the
engineering community in being able to
take data and go from them to the
concise to the concise signal model on
one very simple instance of this is
what's known as the dictionary learning
problem so in dictionary learning I'm
given a bunch of data instances so here
these are going to be vectors why these
are living in an m-dimensional space
once we start making some notation and
we imagine that these y collectively
have a sparse representation in a
certain dictionary a which we don't know
ahead of time so I believe that I can
write down y is equal to a times X where
Y is the data is the dictionary and X is
sparse and if I don't know a ahead of
time then my computational problem is
really one of going from the data to the
dictionary so how can i obtain an
estimate you know or maybe in some
circumstances actually exactly recover
this dictionary a so this is a very very
simple problem to write down but it's a
very challenging problem to solve with
any kind of a with any kind of a very
satisfying theory although there are
good they're good engineering and
engineering approaches to this so the
problem is I'm given Y which is close to
a times X is unknown X is unknown X is
sparse and I want to recover a and X and
so if you sit down and you look at this
for a second the first thing that you
notice is that the solution is ambiguous
here so if I were to
mute the columns of a make the
corresponding permutation to the rows of
X I get a solution that's just as good
and so there are in some sense a
combinatorial a large number of optimal
solutions to this problem in any way
that you would you would think to form
to formulate it and so this is a very
basic fact but it turns out to capture
most of what's hard about the problem so
we'll see this has very negative
consequences or at least very
challenging consequences for our ability
to write down global formulations simply
because any kind of a convex um any kind
of a convex relaxation of the problem is
going to have to break the symmetry
somehow okay so there are ambiguities
there's kind of an interesting geometry
to the problem so each of my columns is
sparse combination of the dictionary the
dictionary vectors what this means is
that each of my data vectors actually
lives on a particular union of union of
K dimensional sub spaces so if I imagine
each of these X J's is case sparse then
if i take the collection of n choose K
sub spaces that are spanned by que cette
sets of columns of a my data should lie
on this set now you can turn this around
you can say well ok let's suppose my
data do lie on this set so say I
observed a very large number of points
is this enough to make the problem well
posed you know since this is in some
sense the object that we're trying to
fit and it turns out that the answer is
the answer is yes this is a result due
to Mickey elad and collaborators what it
says is if you take this very large
arrangement of subspaces you put at
least k plus 1 non degenerate points on
each of them then you've in some sense
identified this object so there's it's
it's possible to identify the
factorization up to the inevitable
ambiguity so up to the up to this one so
you know that's that's that's great as
starting to understand when the problem
is well posed
it's a little bit problematic if you
want to work with reasonable data sizes
since this this P is obviously
combinatorially large so this is where
we're here for big data but this is this
is really very large data this is k plus
1 n choose K so if this is all we know
about the problem we might reasonably
ask whether it's whether we should even
be thinking about this at all you know
is this is this simply too complicated
of an object to fit and so there are a
couple of very nice results in machine
learning that say that in some sense no
at least in the sense of generalization
so this is a result by manner and brooke
stein what it says is if i find some
good way to fit the dictionary to data
so if i find a way of getting a getting
an a that works well on the data samples
that I've seen then I expect that I
won't be fooling myself so the expected
error over new samples is not too much
worse than what we see on the training
data and in particular the numerator
here is just m times x n here the
dictionary was M by n so you know at
first glance it's actually not entirely
obvious that this would be that this
would be true you know here we have a
very very complicated object but it says
that if we can find a good dictionary
then actually actually we should we
should do okay on new data so in some
sense the problem might not be as bad as
we thought okay so armed with that
intuition we can go about thinking about
ways of finding the dictionary and
there's a very very popular approach
very successful approach in applications
which says I write down an energy
function it's capturing some quality of
approximation on the data that I've seen
so this is this this first term here and
also involves some kind of sparsity
encouraging regularizer so that's this J
of X here so I write down my my energy
function and I observed that for most
natural J for example if JS in l1 norm
this thing is convex in each of the
terms when the other is
and so the natural idea is to apply
alternating directions so I minimize
over a I minimize over X and hopefully
that takes me to a local optimum and if
you're careful about how you construct
the algorithm then it actually is
possible to get convergence at least to
a stationary point so you're in some
sense getting a local solution now
there's a tremendous amount of work on
this there are a lot of variants many of
them had actually worked quite quite
well I'm not really going to go into too
much detail talking about the various
approaches to this but most of them have
the flavor of doing alternating
directions over a and X so we write down
the energy function and we alternate so
if that can give us a local minimum then
there's a kind of natural question for
analysis which is well is my target
solution to local minimum so you know
say I think about a simplified model of
the problem I imagine that I see why is
a times X X is sparse and satisfies a
random model so for example the entries
in acts are products of independent
Bernoulli random variables and
independent Gaussian random variables or
more generally symmetric sub Gaussian
random variables and under this
probabilistic model I study whether my
my solution of interest actually is a
local minimum and so it's possible to do
do analysis here it's possible to prove
things there's a very nice result due to
Remy group in vol and Karen schnoz that
says that this is the case for square
incoherent dictionaries a and there are
other results for example this is due to
trend goong and myself on which say that
for general / complete dictionaries this
is the case there there there there are
a number of results of this nature
Francis Bach also has work on basically
what you can say is that if you if you
assume that the data follow an
appropriate model so if they actually
are sparse and the coefficients are
random then provided I've seen enough
examples my target solution is a local
minimum
to a natural optimization problem now
you could rightfully ask yourself
whether this is in some sense obvious
you know we we said that we're locally
minimizing a sparsity surrogate and now
you've proved that it's a local optimum
and you know maybe it is I mean I mean
maybe it's it's it's very expected it's
not entirely trivial to analyze so it
turns out that there are some
difficulties for analysis here that come
from the fact that when I linearize this
problem the linearized sub problem that
I have to look at actually doesn't
satisfy some of the most popular
conditions for guaranteeing guaranteeing
l1 recovery so for example you run into
problems that don't have restricted
isometry don't have incoherence and so
you need other ideas so the ideas that
are useful here are ones that work in
problems where you don't have restricted
isometry such as the matrix completion
problem okay but in any case you you use
these tools and you can prove that your
solution of interest is a local minimum
so that's satisfying to an extent but
there's still a gap because we've proved
that the solution is a local minimum and
we know that the algorithm gives us back
a local minimum but we don't know that
they're the same local minimum so we
haven't really yet done a performance
analysis of the algorithm and so the
natural question to ask is whether it's
possible to obtain in some situations
some kind of global result and as far as
we know we know no way of doing this in
general right now so in general the
problem is very hard most of the
difficulties seem to come from the sign
permutation ambiguity its fact that
there's symmetry in the problem but
there is one very special case where it
actually is possible to say something
and that special case is when our target
dictionary a is actually a square matrix
and that matrix is non-singular so if we
imagine that a is M by M non singular
matrix then we can actually turn the
geometry of the problem around a little
bit so instead of thinking about this
complicated collection of columns we
can actually think about the rose okay
so if a is non-singular then clearly the
row space of why is the same as the row
space of X and so instead of trying to
fit a large collection of subspaces to
these data vectors I can imagine that I
should try to find these sparse rows
within the row space of Y so I look for
sparse vectors in a known subspace and
so the good thing here of course is that
this row space of Y is something that I
know ahead of time and again this is a
really a special property of the of the
complete case really a special fact
special property of a being non singular
okay and so if i take the same random
model as before i imagine that the
coefficients are Bernoulli gaussian are
Bernoulli sub Gaussian random variables
then I really don't need to see too many
examples for this problem to become
well-posed so I would say that the
problem is well posed once these rows of
X are the sparse vectors in this known
subspace and so you know you do a little
bit of calculation and you need about
and log and examples for that to happen
under this random model so if i compare
in the complete case i end up with
uniqueness from about n log n random
observations in the over complete case
if i were to think about it in the same
geometry then instead of looking for
sparse vectors in the subspace that i
know i would be looking for sparse
vectors that live in some extension of
this subspace right so here I see the
row space of Y in the over complete case
this is a lower dimensional subspace my
sparse vectors my rows of x would live
in some higher dimensional subspace that
contains it and so you know in some
sense it's clear that finding this
higher dimensional subspace is a more
challenging problem ok so
this complete case is very good for a
uniqueness analysis what are the
implications for algorithms so can we
use this property to get a global
algorithm ok well the natural approach
to this would be to start with a
combinatorial formulation of the problem
i'm looking for a sparse vector in the
row space of y and i would like that not
to be the zero vector so i'm looking for
some linear combination of the rows of
why that is sparse and is not the
trivial linear combination so there are
two parts that are they're challenging
here on this is a non-convex objective
function this is a non-convex constraint
for the objective function it's fairly
clear what to do we at least is the
first thing to try we take this l0 norm
we replace it with the l1 norm and we
minimize that so the question is really
what to do with this constraint that
says that I don't look for the zero
vector and so one thing that you can try
to give a convex way of enforcing this
is just to ask my w the thing that's
making my linear combination here to
live on some a fine hyperplane so I
asked that our transpose W is equal to 1
now the question is what a fine
hyperplane you know I could I could
consider a lot of them one possibility
would be to simply choose our at random
and that actually works if the problem
is very very sparse so if you have about
a square root of log n non zeros in each
column then that even a random choice
works here but for denser scenarios
there's actually a better choice and to
think about this better choice of our
it's better way of breaking the symmetry
here preferring a single row on it's
useful to make a change of variables so
what we would like is we would like that
when i multiply the solution w hat to
this one through why i get one of the
rows of X may be up to scale if i can
guarantee to do that once then i repeat
it n times i get each of the rows of x
and i'll be in good shape
so let's change variables let's select
QB a transpose times W and let's imagine
just for the sake of analysis that I'm
instead minimizing Q transpose X so just
make the substitution here subject to a
and verse r transpose q is equal to 1
well what you can see is if we could
make this a inverse R be the ice
standard basis vector then this
constraint would very strongly encourage
the solution q to pick out the i throw
and in fact you can prove that if the
problem is sparse enough and the random
model holds then then that will happen
with high probability now unfortunately
to be able to choose that directly we
would have to use a and we don't know a
you know our goal is to learn the
dictionary we certainly don't have a
ahead of time what we do have our
superpositions of just a few of the
elements of a so we have access to the
data why and I've assumed that each of
these y JS is a sparse linear
combination of the columns of a and so
as a reasonable substitute here I might
imagine just using YJ as my vector R so
I take the the J that the J dictionary
excuse me the J from the Jade
observation I solve this problem and I
imagine repeating this for many J ok so
this is what the the algorithm would
look like you would have a first step
where you solve a sequence of l1
minimization problems each of these
gives me a vector in the row space of
why and what I'll do is I'll just find a
bunch of those vectors and then I'll
have a second greedy procedure that just
goes and picks out the sparse 'used when
you're independent set from this
collection of vectors okay so we just
repeatedly take the spar syst one um
until until we've found n of them or you
know we've exhausted our
our collection of other examples YJ so I
saw the sequence of l1 minimization
problems and then I use a greedy
algorithm to do the reconstruction okay
and their variants that you can make so
for example it turns out for technical
reasons that sometimes it's actually
better to do this with combinations of a
few of the columns of why this allows
you to get a result that is in some
sense less specific to the distribution
that we've assumed so in particular this
choice of a sum of two columns works for
both Bernoulli Gaussian Bernoulli
rademacher actually general Bernoulli
sub Gaussian models whereas for the the
first one we actually need a Gaussian
model okay but that's in some sense at
least to me that's that's kind of a
technicality here on the important idea
is really that we're looking for the
these rows of X as sparse vectors in
this known subspace the row space of Y
and the data vectors themselves these y
JS really give us a way of breaking the
symmetry so basically we have n
potential solutions here and rows of X
and what the data vectors are doing is
they're they're really helping us to
choose solutions that have the same
support so you know symmetry is a big
challenge for convex relaxation this
allows us to get to get past it in some
sense here okay and so the kind of
mathematical result that you can prove
about this algorithm is you know again
similar in spirit to what I showed you
before although perhaps there are more
technical restrictions so the spirit of
the result is that if the model holds
and the problem is nice enough then the
relaxation works with very high
probability so in particular if you take
your coefficients from a Bernoulli sub
Gaussian model and you've seen enough
samples and here you know what we proved
in the paper is about is that you need
about n squared log squared n
then as long as the problem is sparse
enough this this algorithm is actually
going to recover with high probability
all of the rows of X and so that would
allow you then to subsequently recover
the dictionary okay so that's what you
can prove now it's worth commenting on
this sparsity level so this theta is the
parameter in the Bernoulli model so we
said that each of the elements of X is
non 0 with probability theta so what
this sparsity level is saying is you
know if I have n dictionary atoms then
I'm going to have at most about square
root of n non-zeroes per column so if
you think about the the sparsity level
that we can do here this is about on the
same order as what you might be able to
get in some of the classical results in
in sparse approximation when the
dictionary is known and incoherent so we
gets us gives us a up to about this
square root of n non-zeros per column
now it's worth saying that you can also
prove that the algorithm breaks down at
least in this form when the number of
non zeros is significantly beyond square
root of n so there may be some kind of a
transition here at square root of n but
at least what it says is for a specific
instance of this dictionary learning
problem it's possible to have an
algorithm that you know works globally
just solves a sequence of convex
programs and it gives a recovery
guaranteed and this is actually
something that you see in simulation so
if you if you simulate the algorithm on
here i'm showing varying dictionary size
varying number of non zeros then what
you'll see is that the algorithm that I
described to you this a here has a very
nice property which is that when the
data satisfy the model um if the data
are nice enough the algorithm succeeds
with very high probability that's what
white means here if not then the
algorithm fails with very high
probability and similarly so the second
one here that actually gets a little bit
has a little bit better breakdown point
empirically is
a variant that orthogonal eyeses after
each vector that we find so you can you
can make variants that actually have
better practical performance but this is
kind of a nice property and this is a
property that we don't see as much in
algorithms that weren't designed with
the specific goal in mind so you know
things like the the KSP d or the online
learning work very scalable um but they
don't they don't seem to have this very
nice exact recovery phenomenon at least
in these experiments okay so we kind of
cover a lot of ground so far in the talk
um I guess the the big picture here is
we're really looking for representations
for for visual data that sufficed for
tasks so in particular suffice for
things like recognition or for things
like compact representation you know
maybe compression denoising each of the
methodologies that that I know for
getting getting these kinds of results
suffers from challenges in particular if
we think about the analytical
methodology then we need to think very
carefully about very specific problems
although it's possible to do this in
some cases if we think about the the
computational methodology then we can
really embrace a lot of applications
although there are some very hard
mathematical challenges in how we can
understand performance of algorithms or
how we can get global algorithms for um
for solving these kind of recovery or
approximation problems okay and
obviously there are some very nice
problems for open open work here in in
both directions on in particular in this
dictionary learning problem until very
recently there was absolutely nothing on
the / complete case at least in terms of
global performance guarantees still
there's a lot to be done there there's
not much in terms of in terms of noise
free results and the sparsity that we
can do is fairly limited so we have this
this root end barrier so there's really
still a lot to understand here but you
know at least in both of these
directions we start to see a little bit
of a nap
okay so I'd like to close by thanking my
collaborators so this the low rank and
sparse is joint with Emmanuel and with
Emma the dictionary learning is joint
with dance Spielman and when long and
the computer vision applications are
joint with some of my students and so
with that I will thank you for for your
attention and welcome any questions so
questions sure okay sure so first
assuming the thing that the a conviction
dimensions itself is positive or sparse
or something like that does that help at
all up and be and do nope two cases
where our situations were to receive
actually get the dot product but button
noisia version of that so so the data is
not noticing but you get the noisy
measurements okay something so if you
think about the a kind of models right
that text classification travel miles
alleged event a similar right but they
have some inheritance noise right okay
good so so two questions so the first
one is on how do you put additional
assumptions on the dictionary here and
the answer to that is I really don't
know how to actually and the challenge
is that in some sense you're working
through the inverse of the dictionary
matrix right you're working through this
this w which is reaching in and picking
out the rows of X and so I actually
don't know how to penalize W such that
it would correspond to a non-negative a
right what you would like to do is you
would like to say these rows of W are
coming from the inverse of an A which is
not negative and I don't know how to
pose that constraint in there in a clean
computationally tractable way I would
really like to be able to do that
because that's often the case but I
don't know how to do it on the second
question I think I didn't quite
understand so the second question you
say what if the data are clean there's
no noise in the data but the inner
products are noisy which inner products
are you referring to so so you are
they don't like it might be a low voice
okay okay other questions okay